[Music]
three two one action
hey they should UK up a three okay I
just I know this is part of it yeah we
have a tip for you welcome back to
off-the-record we'll talk about whatever
we want whatever apparently not because
we could talk about whatever we want to
the eye and just offense you guys
everyone's joking no one's really upset
ative okay I am so mad at TIFF right now
we're beefing David was so mad he went
we had to call Nicki yeah exactly he was
so mad she had to come but it always
yells at us all the time okay - you can
actually hear like oh cool I thought you
guys just tuned me out that's why I've
been like and forget okay so what are
you doing today
Oh David cried he cried okay now
everyone knows you're gonna cry David
never cries she cries and yelling [ __ ]
he just no guys this [ __ ] poor out of
his yeah David cries his pillow like his
[ __ ] pills sod with tears that's why
you can't go to sleep
that's why yes I miss omneya cuz he's
like I got stuff your nose what do you
think makes David David we heard his
feelings like a [ __ ] now fool he
says he's really sensitive yup I didn't
he's a cry like that and then that's why
I can't wake up early in the morning to
train with us cuz he every night he's
crying crying crying crying crying you
know what's really really cool all the
girls are planning an all-girl trip and
I'm super excited leaver minded me cuz
he was going like crank crank crying and
I'm like that's what we're not gonna be
doing we're gonna be going wild what are
you guys gonna do
please playing with each other's boobs
and stuff are tops
Oh yours is bigger but does it weigh
more mine weighs more was it denser I
don't know all right we invited buzz but
yeah we tried no that's great honey yeah
absolutely not well you have boobs yeah
well yeah at one time the first city I
ever touched was Gio's I don't know if
you knew that fun fact it happened here
Jake a new did they catch it on camera
yeah it's there I watched that clip back
and I was I was surprised because like a
brunt I'm sorry but I noticed it with my
handy little pulsate you know real quick
yeah yeah I didn't he was like a solo
show that's a touch Steve's dick so you
know he understands is it planned
already we have not planned no but
everyone's in are you guys gonna vote
six classes you never get a chance to go
no we're gonna go somewhere nice summer
call your me like a girl and life is
very laughing that's cute yeah should we
do a guy's trip on the same time retreat
now you have to watch babies I don't
gotta watch no baby yeah you have that
too fur babies dummy got dog sitters
girl you know what as the unbiased party
here you know the girls are going on the
trip you boys considering going 1-1 and
as person that won't be going I think
that I should have the final say and
y'all can't go secret group chats are
you gonna stop us
oh I'm there we got more than one secret
good strange number with no photos let's
just their girls know all the secrets
thank you guys know how many groups hats
do we have you guys have four why are
they the MMA sparring one the gun why am
I wrong the movie the writing one you're
wrong all right you're right you're
wrong on all of them ready yeah whatever
right see what are they then Montel you
serious well then how do I know that
you're how do I know I'm the answer key
I look at your problem like that's wrong
that's wrong
go checks the teacher no wonder word
right no I checked the teacher oh look
at Joe look at listen here's an audit ah
guys have like group chats that are by
category like the MMA and the like the
gun group chat but
to Fight Club I feel like for girls our
categories are this is the group without
April this is the group I used to like
my friend sorry we used to do like girls
night and there was one girl that like
she poses like she had like some some
risky [ __ ] she she ended up on reddit
like she ended up on reddit because of a
really cringey tweet she ended up
already I can't have all that and it was
like it was really crazy well I'll wait
for you to tell me off count it because
now I don't want you to jeopardize
anybody's life dude I've got vald some
information like when I told y'all about
but the person who told me that their
penis was structurally like compatible
with the female g-spot they saw the
video I was like every single female
g-spot yes it's like different forever
blessed you saw the video I'd be curious
between me him and God all right
I said that his dick is good for my
g-spot I'd be like hook me up please
it's always the most [ __ ] guys though
you that's why I ask guys no you don't
think the way girls do you don't think
about it because you don't have girls
that you're so in the beginning right
you're like oh damn this is tight cuz
all these girls want me right but then
after you have so many girls to choose
from that now you're picking the fine
ass girls that you like right so you
know fairness is still tight but then
all that's hitting you up now are like
the [ __ ] gremlins of the girl crew
and you're like [ __ ] man I don't want
this anymore
but what if she's stuck over and really
good day saying so what if the gremlin
is like hey talented gremlin perfect
mouth for every penis that ever lived
but but her breath stinky like hey
hey Tom better wash my dick after you're
lying
you have Gio don't be a hater on the
gremlin girl are the gremlin people in
Kremlin it's all it's all relative all
right it's all to each person I think
guys are scientists
they'll try an experiment along that's
not like how you phrased it you got away
with almost anything if you phrase it
correct we have to test every hypothesis
is her mouth that's on every deck and
make them calm because this is coming
from a mind if someone that doesn't get
hit on like 20% comes in with a
clipboard with three columns he's like
all right trial why no that's how he
wanted it seems dick he was like I just
for scientific purposes science hat on I
mean let's let's look at the difference
like how low guys will go to to nut
versus a girl it's very different right
I have a pretty imagination I don't
really need you know I [ __ ] the couch
so guys would be willing to stick their
dicks in random gas station bathrooms
that say like glory hole yeah I [ __ ] it
it could be another man on the other
side but I don't care you would would
you guys like that I'm just no I'm
speaking for guys you the majority of
guys with I tapped out for a porta potti
yes he did
Victoria's Secret catalog wait but why
there's a lot of reasons why okay I feel
like with guys would you girls jack off
in a porta potti no that's [ __ ] full
of marine [ __ ] why did you jack off in
there do it in my bed and no because
what is the content well it's cause like
when you're like training you know you
get horny you know there's just all
dudes and then so you used to treat you
like Marine Corps okay i'm ryan training
you guys are so reckless with your like
Pinay that like it's always the benefit
outweighs the risk like could I get
caught jerking off in this in this
port-a-potty don't doesn't matter I'm
gonna fence not even getting caught it
smells like [ __ ] in there it smells like
[ __ ] in there and you have a loaded
rifle but you're like hey
you could shoot your dick off or I could
fit it the only place that you could
drop off I would do it yeah
they even have the same you're not a
real marine and tell you rub one out and
a port-a-potty when you're like in the
military so you're just around dudes
like all the time like if you're a girl
in the military in a little bit
average you're a [ __ ] goddess oh so
so cuz they guys want to get with them
so bad cuz they're horny in the field
they'll be like would you like my
sandwich the ratio is even crazier about
what dude about one girl like two girls
that's two dude that's right now it's
two girls three hundreds
I mean but the racial still imbalance is
this point maybe three girls 500 OOTS
I think do they have like their own
sleeping quarters in there oh yeah yeah
cuz I would be scared if that many horny
dudes were around me all the time at
least I'd be frightened it depends on
the service I lived in Hollywood alone
and that was pretty much the same like a
bunch of horny yeah you walk down the
street at night cuz I live like on
Hollywood Boulevard and I would just be
walking to get groceries
I'd walk everywhere cuz parkings a [ __ ]
and so I would walk everywhere but like
you're dealing with the guys that like
just gotta have the nightclubs and they
haven't gotten laid yet and like your
gate surrounded but where you going
where you and they follow you home it's
[ __ ] frightening it's your fault for
being pretty is my fault for being a
female and alone that's it but that's
what I mean though guys are the lowest
of the lows like they will [ __ ] [ __ ]
sewer if they could it's pretty bad it's
it's disgusting that I don't know but I
mean uh what are we talking about we're
talking about a girls trip head
we're talking about the girls how we
would get it however you would get it
even if she said because if she's like I
got bomb mouth like guys would be like
oh really I'm a [ __ ] two finger comer
what a like comment two fingers okay so
you know girls they're going back going
back going back to what the guy was
bragging to you right the guy was like I
got a dick that hits all G spots right
buddy you all know that until you
actually do it you're like oh you
tricked me man this just sucks so but at
the end he still wins yeah if you got it
done exactly but that's your girls this
thought process before a guy if a girl
said hey my mouth can make any guy come
as a perfect shape if after after if
it's not that way we won't go oh man me
you know it's your [ __ ] going into their
[ __ ] no we just don't think that way
like a free lunch where you're like well
it wasn't the best but I'm phool thank
you we just don't think like that we're
just like thanks meanwhile like like all
girls like I feel like during sex
especially like a first time we're like
does he like I well I got I think
because I had to think about that one
because when I was single and like after
a certain amount of weeks without sex
like I just need it like I just if a guy
walks by like any guy walking by him
like them I don't know that's how and so
it is like after six weeks is like my I
learned is my cutoff and so if a guy
proposed that to me at that point like
if I was single and it'd been six weeks
without sex I might just like I think a
lot of guys would I loved a lot of girls
like you just chilling at the club you
would be surprised because then I would
tell these guys I only want sex like I
know one relationship at all you're
right you're right and they wanted the
relationship no yeah it's because always
that you know what yeah it's the thing
this is the thing like so but the one I
want a relationship with you know
I would say I would say the majority of
guys out there are more the relationship
type their more traditional they want to
be with a girlfriend they want it they
want to live that like fairytale romance
the problem is 80% of guys out there are
really it's really hard for them to get
girlfriends like if you ask most guys
like they would only have a handful of
experiences when it comes to girls but
the 20% of guys are the ones that are
actually dating everyone so the girls
are exposed to these jerks and [ __ ]
and all these other guys because that
doesn't reflect the majority of men the
majority of men are just chilling with
their group of guys and then they spend
most of their time with other guys and
they're not dating left and right well
it's also I feel like girls like I don't
know about y'all but my picker was off
for the longest time
well yeah cuz you pick the one that you
have like psychological issues with like
you're like supposed to work out your
psychological issues and that's why I
keep picking the wrong guy like my
pattern was like oh the same bad traits
each time yeah the same red flags every
time and yet I'm like no I could fix
them they're nice these are the same -
yeah I mean the guy the guys go for the
best boob quality in the hottest girl
and then they realize like wait Vince
themselves that there's such great
people
they're so delusional you'll be like the
harder they are the better the person
they are it's like now that you got a
little arm candy you're like I get to
show her off like that adds a little bit
you go to it I think that's a huge part
of it too
it's receive a guy like it's a girl
that's way out of his league or he
thinks she is and he has low self-esteem
that's when guys turned super weird and
insecure like you probably all had this
experience where like you meet someone
cool and you actually like them yeah
everything is genuine and then they get
hella jealous they always want to
control you there they're afraid they're
gonna lose ya all these things having
the things that make them lose you and
then yeah and then you go see yeah
leave me oh my god they push you away
with their own insecurities because they
put you in the other school
it's your fault yeah and then when you
start being human like they're like whoa
I wasn't ready for this you're supposed
to just be huh stop that get hot again
stop crying and then you would like
jerks and players because they're
probably talking to 20 women what
players because jerks and football team
jerks and players oh I was during
players I did arrive you're young when
you're young and it tends to happen not
for everyone but when you're young girls
are attracted to that because they seem
so confident right because they don't
care but the difference is they spread
they're like they don't put all their
eggs in one basket so if they're talking
to 20 girls then it doesn't matter if
one [ __ ] them or get stood up or
whatever because they have to spread the
risk oh yeah I always dated nerds and
funny guys so I think that's why when I
like the ones that I would sleep with
and be like I just want sex they were
like comedian nerd guys and so then they
wanted a relationship so they didn't
have that many girl experience yeah so
it's hard for them but then one time I
dated this guy that I thought was a
nerdy comedian dude and then he actually
was secretly a player and that was like
his like
God Wow mind blown Wow
I mean um Bart's Bart's a close relative
told me we're told told us or told you
what was the story you tell the story
you tell ya I'm a relative that went to
a very school very close to the city
that you grew up in and call me yeah a
big party town okay yeah yeah big big
party at the STD town yeah so he went to
school very close to that area
hmm and there's this girl that gave him
blow job three times and then he was
like hey do you wanna be my girlfriend
he was like she was like ill know and he
was like what the [ __ ] this is crazy you
suck my dick three times I see I would
never suck a dick unless we were dating
oh that's that's P that's too intimate
yeah I cook your dick unless we're
dating you bought me dinner like I know
it is weird he was sad anything he's got
a [ __ ] but it was like really sad
that night yeah you wanted a
relationship yeah but girls would use
this guy for sex
what wait wait yeah he busted nuts
is he really hot some people use it to
validate themselves like I got him no I
mean like yeah like oh I'm so good at
sucking dick but you know and like think
about like I never got practice gon just
be used for validation bi or was she
like a like a good five six you know do
you know what she looks like
yeah so like what's the funny concept
that a girl like this
take that [ __ ] like they like
what if she was just wildly insecure but
she knew that she sucked a mean dick and
she was like or I want to get better at
it
I want to secure my man with my dick
sucking skills well there's a certain
level of power that comes with good dick
sucking skills like you now are in
control okay over me I also get if that
girl was like spreading her skills on
like 20 different guys right if you have
a repeat customer like that person do
you know other people weren't repeat
customers with her mm-hmm
she could be like just running a dick
sucking game all day you know what if
she's trying to get an Xbox in black and
he loves dick
[Music]
and I also think that your close
relative was giving her the attention
that she wanted so then she was like
Alma play with this dude's head and then
get my own like like my own night caught
on yeah and then as soon as he he like
wanted the relationship she was just
like I knew it but nah dude you a my pad
she's all like all these guys ah oh
she stops talking to sick after he asked
her out oh this is getting too personal
yeah huh
that's interesting yeah because if i
hook up with someone I'm not dating
officially then we're using condoms so
I'm not sucking dick like there's I
wouldn't suck dick I wouldn't put my
mouth on a penis that hasn't been tested
yet mmm you're very mean safe yeah I'm
very safe
[Music]